hi everybody I'm Dave Travis I'm the
director of U.S content at Khan Academy
here we are in Philadelphia it's so much
fun if you're here at iste we are too
we're at Booth 1836. if you come by our
booth we're going to introduce you to
con Migo our new artificial intelligence
powered teaching assistant and personal
tutor we're giving away a limited number
of free one-month Trials of conmigo it's
going to revolutionize your teaching
practice powering your interventions to
differentiate your instruction in your
classrooms your superintendent we'll
also tell you about our Khan Academy for
districts to show you how we can support
your classroom support your teachers if
you're a student if you're a lifelong
learner come on by we can answer all
your questions about Khan Academy there
are a lot of us here we're looking
forward to talking to you about the
future of learning that's Booth 1836
come on by tell us what you like tell us
what you don't like ask us questions
can't wait to meet you all